les épais mais tony bonjour merci de
nous accorder un peu de votre temps leur
l'italie débute sa deuxième phase de
déconfinement avec de nouvelles mesures
pour ses habitants comment les italiens
se prépare à sa liste est rien ce n'est
pas de la meilleure manière possible
c'est-à-dire d'abord avec le moral parce
que c'est vrai que c'est d'être très
très long comme confinement les gens
sont très fatigués ils ont beaucoup peur
à beaucoup de bars et restaurants ont
vécu vous lire il se refuse à le faire
parce que ils savent que c'est dangereux
donc les bars et restaurants qui le font
sont sûrs de pouvoir la faire respecter
certaines règles
il faut aussi dire que la vie ne
changera pas énormément parce que
defacto c'est simplement un
déconfinement pour pousser les gens à se
rendre au travail pour la reprise des
activités de production de biens et
services
pour le reste on reste confiné on peut
pas se déplacer en dehors de région on
peut pas aller vraiment ou andreu offert
des activités qui ne sont pas
strictement encadré defacto le
confinement continue mais avec un peu
plus de dérogations
il faudra attendre les prochaines deux
semaines pour voir ce que ça donne s'il
n'y a pas une croissance nouvelle qu'on
espère vraiment pas des cargos d'agents
alors là on va vraiment rentré dans une
phase de déconfinement je pense que
c'est plutôt une phase exploratoire d'un
début de déconfinement alors ce matin le
journal italien corriere della serra
titre c'est l'heure de la responsabilité
les italiens vont devoir être
responsable pour cohabiter avec ce
billet ce virus beaucoup de journalistes
et de collègues etc sont absolument par
un désaccord avec cette façon de dire
c'est lors de la responsabilité il faut
quand même rappeler à bien solférino et
la rue où se anciens et vieux quotidien
existe qu en fait les italiens sont
responsables des puits neuf semaines
c'est-à-dire des pythons les a cloués à
la maison il en respecte
les règles même quand il sortait il
fallait se rendre ce marché pour
comprendre à quel point il était
responsable
avant même de recevoir des confus décret
du président du conseil des ministres
faisant la queue alors avant même qu'on
leur demandait donc c'est pas la peine
de dire il faudra être responsable parce
qu'ils le sont déjà
simplement il faudra continuer est un
responsable à la manière qu'on l'a été
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez je ne
suis pas le directeur du corriere della
serra à eux d'écrire ce qu'ils veulent
alors il ya aussi une sorte de
déconfinement par région parce qu'on
sait que chaque région a élaboré un
petit peu sont ces ordonnances sur son
territoire par exemple on va prendre le
cas de la lombardie et la vénétie où les
masques sont obligatoires dès qu'on sort
de chez soi alors que le gouvernement
recommande plutôt dans l'est de le
porter dans l'est de les porter dans les
lieux clos comme les magasins ou les
transports en commun une chose est sûre
les écoles elles vont rester fermés
jusqu'au mois de septembre comment les
autorités vont s'organiser pour éviter
un retard trop important chez les écoles
et les étudiants des fantômes devant moi
même que prouver ça je vous assure que
l'université il en donne aux cours au
lie depuis la première semaine en
universités n'a jamais arrêté de
travailler de faire ses cours de faire
ces examens ces commissions etc en tout
avance c'est très compliqué c'est pas
non plus au top mais on va comme ça et
c'est comme ça
de l'école élémentaire jusqu'au or à
l'université donc sur le retard des
écoliers nous on ne miserait pas dessus
pour nous ça va être normal que
d'immigration
donc c'est pas ça en même temps vous
savez l'italie est en soi un peu
l'exemple que vous venez donnez de
l'union européenne c'est à dire qu'en
fait on est fragmenté à 20 maisons où
les gens dans certaines règles peut
faire un peu ce fip à la rivière le
ministère des affaires et régionaux à a
fait appel à la cour constitutionnelle
parce que la région calabre tout seul
habit chez moi les balles les
restaurants peuvent ouvrir donc c'est
une manière d'avancer malheureusement
fragmenté dieu m
il ya le bon sens mais en même temps on
avance d'une manière un peu alterné vous
avez bien fait de le remarquer de le
souligner par rapport à lombardie par
rapport à veynes ici donc c'est une
manière de se concerter qui est un peu
compliqué rome n'a pas les pouvoirs
absolus de imposé tout à toutes les
régions ça fait que les gens avancent un
peu elle-même il faut aussi lire et je
reviens à ce qu'on se disait tout à
l'heure
les italiens font déjà eux-mêmes
attention parce qu'ils savent ils ont
quand même peur vu la quantité
malheureusement de mort qu'il ya eu
vous avez parlé de la région de la
calabre qui a autorisé justement
l'ouverture des restaurants et des bars
sans les terrasses il y a quand même un
risque d'une deuxième vague de
contamination
comment les italiens voient devoir cet
assouplissement
concernant justement cette région on
doit avec beaucoup de peurs les autres
présidents ont déjà commencé à parler du
fait de fermer leurs frontières si
toutes les légendes n'assurez pas un tel
respect le président de la région
campanie avait déjà fait savoir que si
la lombardie a autorisé à l'avance
certaine ouverture il a lui-même fermer
les frontières de la région alain
pêchant tous les gens de pouvoir y
rentrer et je vous rappelle que le tgv
est a bien fait milan nabeul donc ils
peuvent et y arriver donc voyez il a la
peur si vous voulez des autres les gens
vis-à-vis de la région éventuels qui
pourraient laisser ouvert tout un tas
d'activités parce qu'il y a très fort la
peur de revoir à augmenter cette comme
qu'on a eu tellement de mal à voir
descendre et qui est loin du point zéro
quand même donc c'est vrai il vient une
manière de se gérer collectivement mais
c'est plutôt la peur et la crainte on
attend en fait ces prochaines deux
semaines c'est une manière de se peser
dans la stratégie connue
il faut quand même rappeler qu'aucun
gouvernement a dû faire face à une telle
situation dans le monde entier depuis la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale aux
personnes c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire prévient en tout cas merci
beaucoup à josé pb tonné d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes politologue à l'université de tours
bagata de rome